let's talk about the cops are doing we
got this story from timcast.com
police seize fuel and supplies from
protesters in ottawa freedom convoy
multiple vehicles and fuel have been
seized police said as they extend their
efforts to end the freedom convoy
basically they're now
saying anybody who brings in fuel is
going to be aiding them it's illegal
anybody who provides material support
and there's even an insinuation by
trudeau that americans are interfering
and they want to look into where this
funding is coming from well i don't know
what canada is going to be able to do to
an american who gave five bucks on give
send go i just don't see them pulling
anything off but yo how insane is this
getting they declared a state of
emergency in ottawa
you know
i saw a story on if it's true that
ottawa cops are exempt from the vaccine
mandates
this is how they play the game
the the enforcers get special acts it's
like the hunger games man
wow
yeah
no nothing to say no way oh geez so much
to say
uh how do i
start to think i take it all in every
now and then every time
every now and again it's kind of like a
mexican standoff here we're looking at
who's going to say something first i
don't want to think about this how do
you talk about civil disobedience like
okay
what they're doing is civilly illegal
probably illegal what the hell does that
even mean illegal well it was what was
crazy to me was was seeing like the the
brand account for the ottawa police
department like cheering on gofundme's
decision to you know take this money
away from the truckers you have like
this unholy alliance of like the
government law enforcement big
corporations you know and then you have
this like work you have these who are
just like taking away the the rights of
the working-class people and you know we
complain about a lot a lot about that in
america but man like it's it's crazy
yeah like the ottawa police just
cheering this on is there a word for
that when the government and big
corporations
are working together to control
yeah there's a word yeah so something
like this is something like fascism yeah
the f word
yeah
i think you're thinking about the f word
yeah so earlier you mentioned how
canadian media is basically controlled
by the government one thing one thing i
find very disturbing is that with the
united states
media we do have media which is
controlled by private corporations but
honestly can you imagine it acting all
that differently if it was controlled
and regulated by the government they
continually cheer for bigger government
they insult people and they smear them
for calling for more freedom and calling
for the restrictions the government
imposes upon the average person to end
and when you look at the situation in
canada like i mentioned it's clear that
our private media is more sympathetic to
their state media in canada and the
views that they hold than they are to
the views of the actual people of our
country or theirs bro
there's no mask anymore
it's funny when the mandate the mask
mandate is over no i mean i mean the
figurative mask that that we
we ever assumed the media was on our
side i'm done having that conversation
it's been 10 years anybody who still
thinks the media is telling the truth is
probably lying to you to be completely
honest like even regular people when you
ask them like the press rates abysmally
low in terms of credibility there was
this funny poll from a few years ago and
it was like who do you trust like how
much trust do you give these
institutions and the press was on the
bottom at like 17 when um what's his
name glenn greenwald got booted out of
the intercept that was a big like red
light for me i that that it's that
structure of that that old media thing
doesn't work anymore you can't be honest
in that situation because there's too
many corporate donors trying to get a
hold of your you and your money yeah
yeah so like it's it's not even that
just that they're biased to one side of
the political aisle they're beholden to
corporate interests a lot of these media
outlets and a lot of the time corporate
in you know obvious as we said before
there's this unholy alliance between
government in america and big
corporations and the media is a part of
that you have like an
institution like the washington post
that's owned by the scent the second
richest man in the world yeah and you
know obviously obviously their coverage
is going to not reflect the views of you
know people in
working class people in ohio or working
class truckers uh speaking out against
these mandates you know they support all
these things you know how i see it i'm
like thinking about the media and it
reminds me of those movie tropes where
it's like there's a wife and then her
husband runs up and she has a gun and
he's like honey it's me put down the gun
and then all of a sudden another like
clone of her husband runs the other side
no no i'm your real husband and she's
like i don't know which one is real i
don't know where that trope came from
like the original movie
but it feels like there's like a normie
regular american sitting on their couch
and we run in and we're like we're
telling you the truth we're challenging
the lies and then you know brian seltzer
runs and he goes don't listen to them
we're we're the truth they're telling
you lies that's exactly i feel sorry for
you no um it's true and i think it's
funny because for years and years right
after trump was elected then was elected
the narrative was you know everything
was fine people trusted the media we had
a great relationship with the public and
then all
dt came along and made him hate us with
all of his rhetoric about how bad the
media is it was like well no you guys
were already pretty terrible and mostly
politicians were willing to bend the
knee to you and then one came around who
wasn't and it opened your eyes to how
unpopular you are because the reason
most people or the very least many
people are sharing for donald trump was
because you hated him and he hated you
and that meant that he was more on your
side than theirs um and i just love to
see their their narrative crumble with
each turn you're talking about how
canada is much more authoritarian than
the us but the fact that the people of
that country have formed literally the
largest convoy that we have ever been
aware of in human history to protest
their government's mandates is really
incredible it's a giant white pill there
was a big convoy of uh diesel trucks
about a thousand years ago
yes of course no i i understand
i understand i i understand it's a more
recent phenomenon with the trucks but
also the largest convoy before this was
like five miles five miles and now this
is 45 miles donald donald trump
demonized and attacked the media because
people hate them yes because people got
access to the internet and it was like
the knowledge was beamed down to the
people and then all of a sudden they
were like hey wait a minute they're
lying to us about everything and then
trump was like that's right
trump is a symptom of not the creator of
but of course the media is now saying
donald trump he started all of this in
2007 i was doing youtube videos a lot
and i was getting real political i was
like we need to direct to the politician
now we have internet video we don't need
secret service putin and barack obama
could get on a video chat and just talk
hang out and chill i could get on a
video chat with barack no security
issues we just chat so we need that more
and i
i was telling it to youtube and the
people the youtube um corporate
headquarters was listening and they're
like yeah let's do youtube debates so
they created this thing but then cnn get
in on it and they're like no no we're
gonna do the cnn youtube debates and
we're gonna water down all your
questions so i asked barack like
what's up with the federal reserve why
do we have this system in place that's
been robbing creating interest and i was
talking about fractional reserve and um
they didn't air it they wouldn't hear
that they aired all these softball
questions so cnn was the second guy he's
like no i'm your husband ian how what
was his response to that uh barack yeah
he didn't hear oh he didn't even hear it
okay
so you're saying cnn didn't give him the
question i thought you had an
opportunity to digitally ask the
questions remember later remember they
did those town halls and all of the
people in town hall turned out to be
democrat operatives yeah
or like activists or whatever and i mean
who's rigged man and who's surprised by
it even the presidential debates when
they actually have their quote unquote
opposition across from them it's just a
press conference anyway the person
throws their slogans out there and then
their opponent throws their slogans out
there yeah but do you hear republicans
are now going to boycott the uh the
commission on debates debates really
there's probably not going to be a
debate unless the democrats come to them
for a debate this idea of odd debate
also bothers me now we're a place where
you can pop on skype or whatever and
video chat every monday through friday
from 6pm to 7pm with you whoever you
want and everyone can watch
come on 21st century yeah yeah like
shows like this one like have really
really changed the game and like you
know we we you know we're going to talk
about joe wrote we were going to talk
about joe rogan soon it's like
you know shows like your shows like
rogan's shows like tucker carlson's that
draw all of these eyeballs because they
don't bend to institutional powers and
corporate media are a threat to those
are a threat and obviously you've been
targeted with cancelled culture and
obviously the cancel culture knives have
come down with joe for joe rogan and
tucker carlson the only reason for it is
because instead of telling the truth
these institutional powers have now
chosen that they're just gonna they're
gonna pressure corporations to censor
their opposition
do you notice a lot of corporate
interference when you're working with
like just candidacy and
like
positioning your candidates on social
media and stuff do you feel like
pushback from corporations while you're
doing it you have to navigate through
that kind of thing well i mean no
because we wouldn't really work with
anybody who is so beholden to corporate
powers like we don't obviously we were a
company of seven people and we would
never we would never do that and you
know what's what's really what really
sucks is that like there are a lot of
members of congress that i'm sure most
republicans probably like and respect a
lot who take a lot of money from big
tech and take a lot of money from and so
they and part of the reason i think he's
asking if with the candidates you work
with are they being censored and shut
down oh yeah yeah we have to face that
all the time and it's it's on so one of
the one of the clients that we work with
is american principles project shout out
to terry schilling and john schweppe and
before we worked with them this happened
during the last election cycle but they
they had their facebook demonetized
because they ran an ad in michigan that
opposed biological men and women's
sports and the way facebook works is in
order to get a fact check a fact checker
actually has to write a fact check of
your thing so some and obviously the
fact checkers are complete liars like
these political
but so a fact tracker wrote a fact check
on on on an ad that opposed biological
men and women's sports and they got
their facebook account to monetize for
that and so it's stuff like that that
happens all the time it's it's it's
remarkable that uh i mean it's it
we're in an amalgam of all these
different dystopian novels it's like all
of these writers could see a piece but
not the whole
because you know in this instance it's
very uh
the fact checkers are keeping us from
knowing things the major corporations
are you know stifling free enterprise
it's like it's like the inversion
everything wars peace you know etc etc
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you